Speaker 1: teve from Chicago.
Steve, welcome. You're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. I was just wondering, I saw
your video about the the decision that was leaked
for the Supreme Court. Yes. And I know that
towards the end you were kind of talking about
next steps or what could happen if this
happened. I kind of I feel like you're
usually pretty rational. I kind of felt like your
thought process was like, do you actually think
that's something realistically that would happen?
Speaker 1: Listen, I did I did a follow up on
Wednesday where I say I'm not literally claiming
that in the next few months they're going to try
to ban interracial marriage. That's not what
I'm saying. What I am saying is you don't stop
with one of your biggest victories and say,
now we're satisfied we're not doing anything
else. Charlie Kirk literally said, If you can get
rid of Roe v Wade, anything is possible. So even
they are saying it. So, yes, I do think they're
going to try to go further. I think it might be
gay marriage. I think it could be, you know,
access to contraception with no co-pays. But,
yes, I think they're going to try to go further.
Speaker 4: Okay. I mean, I, I really don't I mean,
I'm not saying that they wouldn't we they
wouldn't go for anything else. I just
don't think I'd really seen much
movement of, like, pushing for,
like getting rid of interracial marriages or.
Speaker 1: Okay. But I'm not sure. Steve, are you
did you listen to it? Did you hear what I said?
Speaker 4: Yeah. I heard what you said.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yeah. I'm also.
Speaker 4: Agreeing with anything's possible.
Speaker 1: But I've not seen any movement in
the last few days since the decision leaked
to try to ban interracial marriage. But there's a
list of things which some of these conservatives
are also against. And my view is they're not
going to stop with abortion. But I agree with
you. In the last four days, they've not said
we want to ban interracial marriage. We're on
absolutely the same page, Steve.
Speaker 4: No, I'm asking you
there. I'm saying also not even counting the past
four days, looking at what they would like to do,
I don't think that's even close to the top
of something that would be within the next
years or any time like any relevant time.
Speaker 1: You think they would you agree
that they would gladly try to get rid
of no copayment access to contraception
as part of Obamacare? You think that's
something they would want to get rid of?
Speaker 4: I think that would be definitely
I don't I don't think that's a top choice,
but I think it's definitely more realistic than
them being like, let's get rid of gay marriage.
Speaker 1: Okay. I think I think many of them
would love to get rid of gay marriage. But
listen, let's just give it time and then
we'll we'll see. But I don't think this
is the end. Let's I'll just put it that way.
Speaker 4: Okay. I, I just I want to clarification
because I just I maybe I missed your follow up.
It kind of just sounded that you thought like
literally next step would be get rid of, like, gay
marriage and stuff like that. And it didn't seem
like there's been any like major push for that.
Speaker 1: Right? Yeah. I gave a list of,
you know, a half dozen things.
Let's see what they do next.
Speaker 4: All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
All right. There's Steve from Chicago.